foreign
[Music]
what's goody fam
what goody what's goody welcome
to the live joke feedback hour we do
this every single Tuesday
every single Tuesday ever ever ever
every single Tuesday Ever every single
Tuesday
hey welcome to the show now you know you
get feedback on your jokes it's your boy
Joe
l
well
let's get into it
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome aboard everyone welcome to the
joke feedback hour
we already got peeps popping off in here
Alvaro Andrew
John
wasalla Gus good to see all of y'all in
here as we say here in the hot breath of
Earth what's goody what is goody my
friends
y'all can go ahead and start posting yo
jokes
in
the live chat if you do have a joke you
would like some feedback on
do go ahead and post that in a live chat
my co-host
my co-host Yoshi
will be here in just a moment and right
on cue everyone
let's get him in here Yoshi
you alive
I'm here yo
[Applause]
chia
he made it straight off y'all don't
y'all don't know Yoshi Yoshi has a
family
and
he comes straight
off that minivan life he comes straight
from the minivan life in that minivan I
was like skirt skirt I gotta make this
feedback man get out of here
for free
I'm here on my birthday
Yoshi's here straight off the minivan
life we may you know depending on how
much I'll share and repost this we may
just end it you know I'm telling you
right now you're on thin ice okay if you
don't start promoting this when you get
joke feedback do a screen record of it
so then you can then share it and we'll
repost it on our social media
but I'm telling you we've been doing it
for the culture for the culture the the
the cold I'm just saying right now we
love you but
the culture's getting cold
we're gonna need to put something in the
microwave build it up you know let's
let's get cooking we gotta get something
cooking
that's all we're gonna say we're not
here to threaten we're not here to to
hurt any feelings we're just here to
keep it one hunda hello
[Laughter]
those are the words of our wives so
just keep that in mind my friends so
come on in here this is your art I love
those words
yeah exactly so um
what we're gonna do here my oh and look
at that Alvaro just said happy birthday
Joel and he super chatted
five dollars
let's go
and uh before anyone else does a super
chat I have another link where it goes
directly to me so if you guys do
hold on wait a minute
these YouTube middlemen they get a piece
of everything
um so um yeah I have another link for
anyone that wants to send your boy some
birthday love
I appreciate it Alvaro
um that is hilarious I was like wait a
minute wait hold on now
wait a minute
that's hilarious yeah I pinned that link
so there's a link if anyone wants to
donate to uh your bizoy's birthday party
my dog needs a teeth cleaning and I
don't have to pull out a mortgage for it
so yeah and if anybody wants to donate
to the United Negro College Fund which
oh
you pulled that card it's not February
fam no no I said the United Negro
College Fund which is just my kids y'all
can just donate Oh I thought I thought
it was for you no oh I didn't know if
you were trying to go back I was just
trying to say I'm not I don't want to
rep TCU anymore I want to go rep another
school
these kids got to go to school Joel and
uh these uh School prices have not gone
down
more and more people are like you know
you really don't need college and
colleges were like you know what we're
gonna do to counteract that we're going
to make it cost more freedom
is that what's happening
yeah dude less people go to school but
the college is like no we gonna keep
these tuition prices High
dang so y'all can get a high dive at the
swimming pool that's that's
the football team can get ice baths that
yes
in here
all right Bobby said
Joel's birthday fund and happy birthday
Joel hope all your wishes come true may
God bless your day today and every day
throughout the year to come
foreign
oh my gosh thank you so much
how lovely and Alvaro said Joel's
getting older and more ungrateful so
or maybe more grateful for the time that
we have in this world
you know maybe it's that it's all
perspective I appreciate it it is and
you know what I have nothing but immense
gratitude
um Tony Robbins says yep his gratitude
yeah man
gotta be
Tony Robbins Oprah Winfrey you know
those billionaires that you know that we
all want to be like
well we'll hold on to that gratitude uh
we'll we'll pocket that maybe there's
some compounding interest compounding
gratitude perhaps
[Laughter]
to say thank you today it might maximize
for tomorrow yes
all right so we got uh we got some jokes
being posted here in the live chat
um
where'd they go where'd they go
um all right all right yeah maybe today
we're the joke Joel maybe that's what it
is the joke is on us the joke is on us
all right
okay all right oh wait hold on where'd
it go
oh no
all right there it is
all right so 3K Coast posted a joke
um Andrew Lapointe and Alvaro okay all
right we got some jokes cooking off in
here so we're gonna go ahead and jump in
here we're gonna keep it to a tight
hour today
we're sticking to it this time Chris
grullon said happy birthday thanks fam
um
with
um but yes we are uh
I'm gonna keep it to a tight hour today
I've got birthday activities
a birthday activities yay yay let's get
it
[Laughter]
oh
being a good person is so annoying
sometimes
it can be it can be
I'll yell at my mom why did you raise me
right
[Laughter]
all right anyway
now that we got that out of our system
okay keto Carol posting a joke
do you know happy birthday I sent you a
couple coffees through your link tree
no venmo in Canada oh snap thank you
how exciting
all right
well thank you so much for that love and
support there do you know man I need to
it's your birthday every day
oh Jessica asked earlier what kind of
joke a stand-up bit Yeah Jessica
um it's a joke uh typically something
that has a premise and a punch line
is uh the best that can fit like within
the characters that you can type in with
inside of YouTube or Facebook and will
let you write more characters but we try
to say keep it to
I don't know what the character count is
but probably like 150 maybe 200
characters maybe yeah
and it's usually just uh like joke like
it's like a one-liner if possible but
yeah whatever will fit and as you watch
the show Jessica
um you may get a feel for the types of
jokes people are posting like the length
of uh the jokes and stuff but it could
be the old joke it's just like the
beginning of the joke right yeah or
something you would like feedback on
yeah for sure um yeah just um
yeah I think I think you'll get that
you'll see what other peeps are doing
here as we get into it here
um so
first joke I'm seeing
I think it is uh I think it's Alvaro
um
Alvaro alvaro's first joke
of the January 24th
joke feedback hour here we go
I discovered the
I discovered the angle that makes me
look good in pictures 180 degrees away
from the camera
all right
I like that
um
uh let me get the timer hold on
yeah
there we go I think how to make it like
any better
yeah I think if it could just end on 180
degrees like
you know like sometimes
there's a punch line and then we keep
talking but you want to end on the
punchline and it seems that
um
maybe in front of the camera at 180
degrees so I discovered the angle that
makes me look good in pictures
180 degrees away from the camera but 180
degrees isn't an angle so is there like
an angle
like a right angle maybe I tried to find
the angle that makes me look good in
pictures
but it wasn't right like right angle um
180 degrees
you know what I mean like 180 degrees
isn't an angle is all I'm thinking there
um
it's not technically an ankle but it
works as an angle
yeah
I'm just trying to think
like what do you what do people call it
when they're trying to take a picture
I can't think of anything else other
than the right angle
right
like so maybe I discovered the right
angle that makes me look good in
pictures is better
but
it may work as is as well
I think that's probably the only thing
I'd say is maybe the right angle because
the angle part but the right angle is
usually like
you know I don't know if this is just
you know my wife
only takes pictures at certain angles
does not take pictures at like
other certain angles so I think maybe
just the right angle
I discovered the right angle that makes
me look good in pictures
yeah 180 degrees
away from the camera
it just doesn't
yeah it just doesn't punch for me like
180 degrees away from the camera it just
needs to be like tighter
this is not a good start
no this is a great start
no no what about my back
to the camera
fly back to the camera yeah
I discovered the angled
but something else people say is like
they're looking for their good side so
maybe it's his back
side
oh maybe I discovered my good side that
makes me look good in pictures
my back to the camera my back
yeah my backside
I discovered the angle that
my goods my most photogenic
side is my backside
that could work
yeah
more of an only fans thing
ooh get my good side but he said he uses
it when there's a photographer in the
venue
so okay so with that context you could
literally say like oh get my good side
and then you just turn your back to the
camera and then it says the joke
physically yeah if you work it out yeah
if you actually
yeah if you describe this and actually
do an act out I think it would work
yeah
I think yeah I think the act out makes
this joke punchier
because if you say I mean even as a joke
I discovered the angle that makes me
look good in pictures and then you turn
around
180 degrees away from the camera like
now that would be fun
cool The Blind Side Jessica said Blind
Side
that's funny
um
Robert said I discovered my best profile
the back of my head
I like that
yeah sorry I was distracted that
um keto Carol sent me some birthday
money so thank you so much there
[Music]
thank you there keto Carol appreciate
the love there
I'll be sure to go get some sugary treat
some very keto sugar treat with that
nice
but yeah
I think that I think we went a little
over on that one but you know we're
getting the juices flowing here we're
warming up right now yeah
smoking
next joke I'm seeing here
is
um
oh wait hold on
okay Andrew Lapointe is what I'm seeing
next it's a two-parter
Andrew
I like to soothe my anxiety by listening
to noise my favorite is brown noise I
was surprised to find out that you
listen to that on a meditation app
I thought the only place you listen to
Brown noise was in the Taco Bell
bathroom
or restaurant
I I
thought that's where it was going
I got it
um it's not bad it's not a bad joke I
like
I like the bathroom humor I just think
you can get there a little faster
yeah
I was surprised to find out you listened
to that on meditation app so I think he
could condense that to like
I like to soothe my anxiety by listening
to Brown noise on a meditation app
it's called Taco Bell
something like that you know so it's
like the app is the Taco Bell app
that's actually really good that you're
listening to Brown noise I mean and I
think
even it's called a Taco Bell restroom
yeah
yeah that works that definitely works
that's right
yeah I like that yeah well done and
Robert is asking our Facebook group
where to post the joke just post it here
in the live stream
and uh if you're watching the Facebook
group or on YouTube
um and we will be sure to read it
and uh
we're also gonna start sending out
more uh emails so if y'all want to jump
on our email list then you can stay
reminded on when we're going live and
such
feel free to join that linked in uh the
comments where there's also a link to
Joel's birthday
slash wife fund
um if anyone's looking
just to um
support a kid
who didn't call in
call to action
we're here
um
next up I'm seeing 3K Coast
coming in hot here
it was recently on Shark Tank I pitched
a Cuban barber shop for cancer patients
I think it missed the mark
[Music]
so I'm guessing that's word play on Mark
Cuban
um
[Laughter]
unless it was a joke where it was like I
recently was on Shark Tank and I pitched
a Cuban Barbara
the all caps really makes it funnier for
sure
I think this is 3K Coast first live
stream and we're roasting it now we're
just having fun
yeah I mean I get it it's um it's like a
word play
yeah this is better as a twit as a tweet
than it is yeah as a stage mostly
because people aren't going to get the
uh
the like it's hard to
just hear this on stage and know what
you're talking about
yeah I mean you're going to be relying
on people
knowing Shark Tank and then also knowing
Mark Cuban is on there and it's like
relying on a now if people know Shark
Tank they may get it but even then
yeah maybe a tweet for this like on
stage I feel like this is going to be
one that's like
oh yeah and then the whole Cuban barber
shop for cancer patients like that's
just so much
[Laughter]
I don't seem relevant does it no I I
respect the creativity behind it
yeah but
um yeah it yeah I get the word play
though Cuban Mark Cuban so structurally
I get where they went I see the joke I
just don't see it really translating the
stage but
try it out and let us know if we're
wrong but I feel pretty good about that
one not doing good
hilarious
oh and Jessica said I think it has to do
with cancer patients not needing a
barber
gotcha okay so that it is more relevant
not still not funny but
I do see the relevance now
thank you for clarifying that Jessica
Jessica's on a roll here thank you
Jessica
[Laughter]
um thanks for clarifying the not funny
part but that actually did because I I
missed that part about them not having
hair so
yeah that definitely clarifies it which
makes us think oh we got to be smart to
get this yeah which just so you know as
an audience
they're not smart I'm just saying the
majority of people just aren't gonna
like make that click in that connection
but you know who is smart DJ Yoshi just
sent your boy a birthday
let's go
[Music]
awesome
all right this is worth it now we may
have missed you bucks
you know six months down the road you
know what's crazy guys today is actually
my birthday
every week
every week's a new holiday
a new holiday
it's my dog's birthday it's the birthday
of my dog just the day that we got them
out yeah it's in his guide today
um next up it looks like we have
Dino Primo
is what I'm looking at here
this one's yours
oh is it yeah
but we just read the Mark Cuban one oh
yeah yeah that's right okay my work
installed a security lock inside the
bathroom
you can enter no problem but to leave
you must remember to swipe twice
this is a true thing
um inside the bathroom you can enter no
problem
to swipe twice I wonder if there's like
a swipe wipe
word play there you know
yeah
um it's interesting I just don't know if
it's funny
yeah yeah
especially that it's true it feels like
the joke would be something around like
the lock is inside the bathroom no
problem but to leave remember to swipe
twice
um
yeah right now it's just I think he's
going for like a Fray like a word play
on swipe and white Maybe
but
he said that was my worry not
interesting but not funny
um
so I was reading the comments sorry oh
let me uh
let's give him a little more time there
uh let's give him another 30 seconds
there because I yeah
um I got a little add in the comments
there so yeah I guess there's just no
premise like what is the premise here
like I think he went for a word play but
it's just kind of eh so yeah and also
there's no feeling of what do you feel
about it you're just telling us a fact
right now right so yeah there's no use
this joke you're just telling us
something it's almost like you read
you're reading a news article
so it's it's missing sort of the punch
part
so this actually feels like a pretty
good premise but if you have to remember
to swipe twice and then something after
that like
either like I've only been trained to
swipe once or
uh or it could be we now have an excuse
to be in the bathroom so long like a
joke about how people at work sit in the
bathroom on their phones for a long time
or something like that
yeah
maybe something there
um but that is interesting now it's just
figuring out maybe a funny reason for
why they put the lock in there maybe
your job where do you work maybe that
could add some context for maybe why
it's funny or not
yeah
uh yeah it sounds interesting and it
sounds disturbing at the same time
yeah
but cool beans thanks for uh sharing
there
hey
somebody asked if we missed keto Carol's
joke
um I don't see it I wonder if it got
flagged let me check
um my email to see if anyone else sent
me any money I don't see any
oh
[Laughter]
oh my God
imagine if she had to put the joke
feedback inside the donation
yes all jokes could be submitted to
venmo and
um
get to the top of the line
oh so interesting keto Carol's joke was
before his it didn't show up
no she said it might have gotten clagged
yeah it didn't show up in the live
like in the ecamm feed we have but I see
it here on YouTube so um I'll read it
straight from YouTube
um
I think the lumber sexual look is super
hot if you don't know what that is
all right I hold on I messed it up hold
on let me
sorry all right let me reset here all
right all right this is the one action
foreign
[Laughter]
I think the lumber sexual look is super
hot if you don't know what this is It's
a guy that has a beard straight out of
the 1800s and looks like he can split a
pile of wood and me in half
my heavens
all right no she liked that one okay I
did like that one I actually don't think
you need the half part just
split uh Apollo wood and me and just
ended at that
yeah
yeah I'm thinking that um
yeah yeah I agree I I think I think it's
building up so that he can split a pile
of wood so I think it could be she's the
misdirect
so if you build up that he looks like a
lumberjack it looks like he can split
me
or like split I I mean me in half maybe
I don't know if you need a pile of wood
and me it's kind of like and me is the
misdirect
yeah
so if you don't know what this is It's a
guy that has a beard
I think yeah it's like a guy that looks
like a lumberjack with a beard straight
out of the 1800s that looks like he can
split me in half
a pile of me in half I mean I'm just
trying to say like
I'm just trying to get to that misdirect
you know
yeah I mean I think the way that you
just said it and then I think you do
have to use the wood part
so you get the splitting
because I think that's what me isn't
okay yeah yeah
so split a pile of wood
and me
yes yeah that's yeah that that yeah that
makes it a little more easy to yeah
a little more clear than clever there
yeah and I was trying to I was I'm
racking my brain trying to figure out if
there's a wood reference but I can't
think of it obviously wood is also
another synonym for you say yes so there
could yeah there's maybe other
lumberjack
or like types of wood
um yeah there may be different things
that like that are in The Lumberjack
world that could be also seen as sexual
like splitting wood splitting me there
may be other examples yeah um yeah
I like that
yeah I don't hate it though
and I think the other thing is
um
uh
just like going in and just saying I
like Lumberjack man
who are describing
and then go into who can split me and
split that without
doing like if you don't know what that
is
this is what it is just go straight into
your emotion about it and then describe
it and then go into the punchline yeah I
have a lumberjack fetish like you could
just get to it quicker yeah
my type is Lumberjacks yeah just I think
just getting into it quicker yeah good
point
get to the splitting
we just got demonetized
um on that and
um
that's why I was flagged that's why I
was flagged yeah get to the splitting
that's good for the brand
and that's gonna be my my shangillis
moment in five years someone's gonna dig
up
one of the Thousand live streams I've
done he said get to the splitting
to a female online
he said get to the splitting and he
meant it and he didn't ask for
permission he meant it he meant it
uh
uh next joke
I mean it worked for Shane he's killing
it so
killing it
hell in it and Louie's Back did you see
that
like he's back back or the show he's
bizak he's he's on all the pods he's
doing a live stream comedy special at
Madison Square Garden this Saturday
oh wow and it's gonna be available for
like two weeks and then it's gone
forever and then he's releasing
a new comedy special so he's releasing
this one and then he has another one
he's going to release after all this is
done so he was on he's been on all the
podcasts the past like week uh promoting
it he's back
now none of them talked about him
getting canceled I guess we're just
gonna
[Laughter]
I mean where you been
maybe maybe they have I haven't listened
all the podcasts
but uh I'm not yeah but it is
I mean what can you say so how how does
it feel to be a white guy that recovered
from being canceled bounce back yeah
yeah I mean he's definitely I mean he's
back he sold out mad Square Garden
I mean the thing with Louis he was never
I mean I guess he was kind of gone for a
little bit but he's always had a fan
base I mean Louie Louie built everything
himself so he owns everything and his
audience so it's like he never I don't
know
like he's bouncing back because he's
been doing this almost 40 years and
built a fan base that knows and trucks
not not to excuse anything that he's
done
if I remember correctly Louis was one of
the first
people who I remember not even fighting
the accusations and just being like yep
I did it I was a terrible person I am
sorry there was no like waiting period
there was no like oh you know they're
lying blah blah blah there was no going
back and forth about it he was just like
yep I messed up I did exactly what those
people said and I'm so sorry yeah that I
remember I was like oh wow that's
different
yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm just like
I didn't do that and then you get
receipts you're like yeah you kind of
did
so maybe maybe people are forgiving
maybe that's what it is
oh that's very
yeah it'll be interesting
um to see if anybody if there is I don't
I mean yeah I was gonna say if there's
any backlash but
I don't know I I'm I'm more
he's always had a way to stick it to
Hollywood and what's funny is Netflix is
about to release a live stream special
with Chris Rock and Louie just slides in
and beats them to it I just I love that
part of it they like literally Netflix
about to be like are live stream special
first ever and then Louie's like oh I
sold out math Square Garden I'm gonna
live stream it on my website thanks
Netflix like
he's he's always been one step ahead
for sure yeah
that'll give him credit for he's
definitely
yeah he stays on top of it for sure but
it's also like just the jokes man the
dude we saw him yeah we went and saw him
when he came to Atlanta
it was
great material
so good bro
it's just another level yeah and he did
it at a black club with a majority black
audience
there's just so many levels to this that
was so many levels I was like
um
that's comedy
we need to do better what
crazy
yeah he had some bangers in that set too
yeah
all right
so next joke here
Ty Erskine
just me or you I forgot uh
I'll read it
um the first time I got uh
[Laughter]
while I volunteer to read this
like this one
dang man spray holy water on this joke
right before
you gotta all hold hands and pray on
this one
bruh
do you have like a sound effect has
I have this one I have that one
all right let's muscle through it all
right the first time quiet on the set
take two
and action
the first time I got
oh keto Carol said someone pay him 25 to
read this one
bad idea Linked In the live chat
is the Joe buyers birthday fund if you
want to hear me read it
[Laughter]
um
first time I got my
boots licked I laughed like the
Pillsbury Doughboy
that tickles
foreign
[Laughter]
here's the feedback you can do better
than this joke
there it is
like because here's the thing if you put
a joke like this out there right this
then becomes like your brand so and
there's no really like
personality to this
other than you're making a reference to
the Pillsbury Doughboy
um I I just think it's like
what's the word
it could be better I feel like you're a
better joke writer than this
yeah now another positive if you like
doing voices go for it like if if you
like doing characters and things in the
Pillsbury Doughboy is an example of how
you can do that go for it look for other
ways you can do characters and stuff
that is more personal and unique to you
and a joke that you could be proud of
uh in a year
yeah
cool thanks for sharing that time
uh
all right so let's get let's get rolling
here because we gotta we gotta keep this
one tight today so we're gonna
um keep it running Steve just what a
contrast
I haven't even read the joke I'm just
looking at the profile pictures
Steve looks like he's got a 401k yeah
there's like there's a gooch joke from
TY
in a very like serious
photo and then Steve
just like
he looks like the lawyer standing next
to Ty who's like making him read the
apology note for this joke
oh
foreign
I looked in a mirror and didn't
recognize myself because I was drunk and
it was a window and it was my neighbor's
wife screaming
[Laughter]
what are we doing here
oh my gosh
he he
wow you really surprised us there Steve
I gave Steve too much credit
okay uh I looked in the mirror and did
recognize myself
I think this is just kind of all over
the place a little bit
I don't get the premise like what are we
actually
what are we doing yeah I mean the
misdirect is clearly he's set up he was
looking in a mirror but really he was
looking through his neighbor's window
like that's the misdirect I looked in a
mirror and didn't recognize myself
punchline
I was looking in the neighbor's window
basically
okay so maybe we just need that I was
drunk
part
and it was my neighbor's wife screaming
but also there's no context to what why
she's screaming
I mean look at his profile picture
oh
laughs
um
but yeah yeah we yeah we need more
context I see
now I think this is a prime example of
like
Steve
learning the misdirect and understanding
like okay I'm trying to set up that it
was a mirror but the misdirect is that
it was a window and it was my neighbor
like I see
I see like I see the mechanics at work
here so just keep working on it Steve
you clearly have like a grasp of or I
want to set them up to think one way and
then the punchline misdirects into
another way but for this one it's a bit
wordy so just keep working on it and try
to work on things that are true
um as well because this isn't this is a
misdirect for the sake of a silly
misdirect but so just keep practicing
joke writing as you'll write 20 and keep
one of them so you're on the right track
so just keep working that all right set
up to think this way and the punch line
creates a misdirect and um you'll find
some keepers
yeah feedback there
pretty solid
uh Bobby my husband's wanting more
loving from me but it's hard to get
turned on by you turn this down you're
missing out on an investment of Millions
I'm blaming Putin because I ain't Putin
out
all right
here's what I say
I enjoyed the punchline yeah I would
just want to get to it just a little
faster
um
I think you can just start but it's hard
to get turned on by
and then go
like
I don't even know if you need all the
other pieces before
um yeah I think the joke is the Putin
word play right so yeah it's like my
husband's wanting more loving from me
but I told him to blame Putin because I
ain't Putin out
um because
I ain't yeah now like I think just
getting to that part quicker
yeah
you know
because I think the investment yeah
that's about Millions yeah yeah I don't
think it helps the joke though
nah the Putin is where the the puddin is
Putin
all right let's keep it moving here
memory
it's never a good idea to drink and
drive I find it better to drink
beforehand so you can focus on just
driving after
[Laughter]
nice
that's solid
um
yeah
I get it yeah it's all there
yeah I mean I feel like I've heard
similar jokes before okay
um
just to keep it a bean I mean but
I mean it's still a good joke but I feel
like I have heard similar things before
like yeah if you're drinking don't drive
because you pull over so you don't spill
it
like I don't know if you guys heard
these throwaway lines and comedy clubs
before not saying memories stole it I
just think it's kind of like a more
common joke
for sure
um I would also say like the I find it
better to drink beforehand
just say
I prefer I drink beforehand it's like
driving after just make it about you
because that way then you can add more
stuff to it and then it becomes like
about you and then it doesn't feel like
a hedgeburg joke or like uh you know I'm
saying doesn't feel like a one-liner
kind of thing it's about you
cool nice thanks for sharing memory
um
what Salu said we missed his joke before
um before
maybe a YouTube flagged it
oh yeah yeah a girl asked me how big my
eggplant Emoji is
I said I can't it's a hippo violation
I don't get it
a hippo violation
hippo is uh or I think it's a word play
on HIPAA as you're not allowed to
discuss medical information publicly
oh so he's saying hippo like it's like
so big it's like a hippo yeah like I'm
not allowed to discuss it with other
people
ah yeah okay no that context you have to
know but it's like a hit I think it's
it's a word play on HIPAA yeah
but you gotta know that you gotta even
know what HIPAA is on
that he's like in medicine because I
think that would help the joke
because you're just saying hippo HIPAA
and No One's Gonna Get It
okay
okay cool
hip Poe violation
he says okay cool
nice
all right
um
this is from our Facebook group this is
Olga
as older I get as longer it takes me to
grow my hair down my breasts you think
this joke needs a punchline no this joke
needs a push-up
all right
I don't hate it
no I don't hate it either or a press the
older I get
I don't think
I don't I think it's a long clear of
like takes me to grow my hair down my
breasts I think you get to say something
about them sagging
because
the older I get the lower my breasts get
yeah because yeah it's a little more
clear than like the hair down it's like
you got to kind of think about it but
that yeah I like that older you get the
lower your brisket and you think this
joke needs a punchline no it needs a
push-up
yeah
I like that
nice
thanks for sharing that Olga
um
next joke Robert Ma
English is a confusing language
[__] can be good or bad I smoke some
good [__] or he is in some bad [__] it
doesn't change if you add a noun
[__] is bad getting [__] faced is
good
yeah
it's like
I I think part part of this is like this
is a very um
popular like
thread and popular like theme on so many
comedy like clips
of
the like Wars like [__] or MF or things
like that they're just like mean
multiple things like curse words that
can mean multiple times so
I I think the way that this joke would
work better is if you personalize it
yeah how you use the word
versus
just making it generic about English is
a confusing language
yeah
how you use them personally yeah yeah
so even like yeah cool yeah yeah I think
just personalizing it and maybe giving
some real examples from your life will
help to make this more common premise
Uniquely Yours
same thing with like you know Yoshi and
I are married most Comics married are
gonna have marriage jokes really the
only way to make marriage material
Uniquely Yours is to put your personal
point of view and experience and spin on
it
so this is a more common premise but if
you personalize it then it now becomes
uniquely Roberts
this is some game out here today
fighter fighter fighter
I forgot to do Emojis
it'll be Lydia
[Music]
big facts fam big facts laughs
this is all for the free free too
oh
[Laughter]
I'm get I'm getting oh I'm getting
crotcheted in my old age
Yoshi I'm getting
[Music]
you know you talk to old people and they
just have no filter
oh my God yes I'm becoming that person
that's hilarious
stuff that I could care less with the
consequences of repercussions
they said both of you are married how
long have you been together that's
hilarious
that's hilarious
um
all right next joke oh my Heavens
this is from our Facebook group this is
Neil Prettyman
uh we have so many national strategies
in the U.S that we've run out of
original rallying cries for example
which American Tragedy should we never
forget
crowd says 9 11. see none of you
remember the Alamo
see now you remember that
you like this
no
[Laughter]
okay I couldn't tell if you were
laughing or what yeah I was laughing I
was laughing at the
not greatness of it yeah
yeah
um
I don't know it's like
it's I think there's a better way to not
do this in a crowd work environment
and also just put what you're trying to
say like
it's almost like
uh
there's a lot of tragedies and everyone
remembers the most amazing tragedy I
mean like not the most amazing that
sounds terrible like the biggest
strategy
tragedy of 9 11 but no one remembers the
Alamo
uh uh and I think you just have to have
something in that
but it's just not enough for a punchline
because remember the Alamo in this case
is the punch line
like there's no emotion to this
you're just again stating a fact
interesting yes it's like it's like uh
that's the thing you have to be very
careful about when you're telling jokes
is is your crowd gonna have an aha
moment
versus a haha moment oh that's fire fire
fire fire fire fire
[Music]
you don't want them to have a ah no you
want them to have a
H right that's what you want
and this is a ah kind of moment your
eyes can be in your setups but when you
get to the punch line you don't want it
to be ah you want it to be a high
foreign
this this could be a more broad feedback
I know
I know Comics want to be edgy and I know
they want to have jokes about things
that this is free speech and we gotta
say it because it's our duty
go for it
but
I think first learn how to make mundane
things funny I think first just learn
how to make thing how to make your dog
funny how to make your job funny
learn the skill of joke writing and
turning
just non-funny things into funny jokes
and then you can translate it
to American tragedies and things like
that because yeah people see Bill Burr
Louis CK say crazy things and it's
hilarious
they've been working on it over 30 years
to get to that point and I'm not saying
don't say what you want to say say these
things do it you do you boo I'm just
trying to make it a little easier for
you to like kind of crawl before you
walk just learn how to write jokes about
lesser high-stakes things and work your
way up to that
but yes you do what you want to do but
that that may make it easier for in the
long term
yeah I think it feels
that's the thing about comedy right is
that people make it look so easy oh yeah
other people to like write a joke about
9 11 or about a mass shooting and you're
like oh I think I got a good one on this
and it's like you probably don't
[Laughter]
because here's the thing that's like the
it's the easiest thing to write remember
that that's like the easiest thing to go
for because that's the most shocking
thing but joke writing and comedy isn't
about the shocking factor it's about
being funny
um right just because you shocked
someone that's the thing saying 911 or
saying a tragedy you're going for the
shock Factor but then it has to pay off
with something funny which is why those
comedians that do those high stake jokes
like it's like it's like what is it was
it Jerry Seinfeld that says the higher
the stake of your joke the funnier it
better be it's almost like a diagram
like I'm just like you go in high stakes
that thing better be like up there in
the most hilarious thing possible but
you do high stakes and it's down here
and funny
you just alienated an audience just by
trying to say like a trigger word
boom
all right my wife texted me BRB
we've bought a little we bought a little
more time until she gets back
um
Maybe
she yeah she said BRB so whenever she
gets back we're gonna dip
um
but yeah thanks for sharing their Neil
hope that helps
um
next joke
and all of our feedback comes with
positive intentions and you don't have
to listen to any of it we're just giving
you ours but you should you don't have
to but you should yeah we've been doing
this we've been doing this for some time
don't tell them not to listen Joe you
better listen to this this is fire fire
fire
Emoji Pizza eggplant Emoji did you say
eggplant Emoji hilarious
hahaha
uh okay Jessica posted a joke very nice
okay
I'm so poor all my kids were born by
C-section
C-section eight
section eight
yeah I wonder yeah there may be some
tags there of like food stamps or um
I like that
we're born by C-section I wanted to go
I just want the punchline to be eight
but I don't know if it translates enough
to where it's like I'm so poor all my
kids were born C-section
eight
I almost I almost feel like I don't know
if the pause
I think the pause has to be during the
sea
I'm so poor all my kids were born by sea
section
yeah yeah that's
um it's tough I yeah I like the joke you
may have to play around with it on stage
of where to pause
or it may you may need to say C-section
C-section eight
um
so Jessica thanks for sharing
I mean it's got all the makings of a
good solid joke
um yeah but I think you just have to
play with the pauses on where people
will expect it
yes and just a friendly reminder my
friends please
tell your fellow comedians about this
show we do every Tuesday if you got joke
feedback screen record it and post it
and if you do it if you post on
Instagram collab with the hot breath pod
account and we'll post it on there
uh as well to get you some exposure uh
but we really want to start building
this thing up so it's um
so people see it and our wives don't
um tell us to stop
I'm literally about to say because it's
worth it but then I said it anyway
um but you know what makes this worth it
is when you hear success stories
like Felix I did my first two open mics
and they went really well I got the
confidence to go up because I posted a
couple jokes on these Tuesday live
streams and got good reactions out of
you guys
[Music]
let's go
that's what's up Felix thanks for
sharing fam that's awesome
that is awesome man
um next joke
that's pretty that's pretty dope
that's pretty dope yo that's awesome
yeah I mean here's what they like we've
given each other feedback and I've
tested a joke that I've gotten feedback
on here with worked like I was like oh
looks like I don't know everything
uh in the community helped me out with a
joke so you know I think that's one of
those things that comedy is definitely
better in groups and the more eyes you
can get on it the better man
oh that's great Jessica said I wish I
found you all sooner I've been looking
for someone to bounce my material off of
for a long time very nice
well
um
I think I just heard my wife this this
is gonna have to be the last one y'all
oh hey it's gonna have to be the last
one
it's my it's my birthday I don't know
that uh
uh you got some birthday money coming in
that this was not for naught yeah this
is under the table she ain't gonna know
about it
was my money
it's off the books
[Laughter]
no I'll let her know we out you this
isn't the secret account I know I know
this is going to the Bitcoin fund no I'm
just kidding
listen all this in crypto
[Laughter]
um
so let's see uh the final
uh
uh John Mondragon my girlfriend broke up
with me last week for being too childish
too bad for her
it was Opposite Day
great
my girlfriend broke up with me last week
for being too childish
too bad for her it was Opposite Day
so
so is he being childish because it was
Opposite Day
yeah I can't tell what part of it is the
opposite part whether the breakup or the
being too childish hell even maybe the
girlfriend part is opposite day
um so that's what I'm wondering it's not
clear
which part first yeah where what it's
not quite true it's yeah it's not quite
clear what the premise is
yeah
but got me last week for being too
childish too bad it was opposite
yeah we just need more of a premise here
he said like opposites day when you were
a kid so she didn't actually break up
with me
my girlfriend broke up with me last week
for being too childish
yeah that's not very clear
opposites day when you were a kid so she
didn't actually break up with me
all right one thing I
one thing to always remember is that
I I forget somebody told me this
but like a joke can't just be the fact
that it didn't happen
it's not enough for a joke you don't get
as high of a
of a
of a surprise just by being like psych
or nope that didn't happen kind of thing
it's not as big of a punch just to say
like psych that didn't happen or negate
something
it's much better to just say what the
actual joke is or what the punchline is
rather than saying nope that didn't
happen because you're almost negate
everything else that was done like
before so just remember that like psych
kind of jokes just won't get bigger as
big as punch as actually stating the
joke
cool yeah yeah there we go yes remember
opposite day but
um yeah he sees what you're saying there
he said okay cool awesome and hilarious
Felix said they skipped my joke after
that
hilarious
I don't know we can't get to all of them
today I know
we normally um
plan to go five to six and then we end
up staying for later to get all of your
jokes in
but
I'm gonna use my birthday as an excuse
to still we still went late but hey
hey
okay yeah
it's been real I appreciate all the
donations to the birthday fund yeah man
happy birthday dude I appreciate you man
I'm glad you get to live another year
you're alive you're doing big things
you're doing big things for the
community
uh you're the manager happy birthday
Mama Gucci gang thank you so much Yoshi
you're the man too for doing this every
week coming straight from family time
straight from family time you come
straight from the minivan to this live
stream yeah yeah for sure I appreciate
you for the sacrifice you make to make
this happen every single Tuesday at 5 PM
which is why we need y'all to share this
post the screen records if you're
getting joke feedback
love likes love likes yeah I mean if you
enjoy this you gotta help us promote it
or otherwise we're just not gonna keep
doing it
I mean we've been doing it for like a
year and a half now you know so I mean
there's a lot of good karma we put out
there so we're challenging you all to
help spread the word because we're a
community for Comics by Comics so tell
your other comics about this so we can
keep doing it yeah
yeah but now alas
lets us in this live stream
y'all we'll see y'all next week
Maybe
[Laughter]
it depends on how much more you donate
yeah right
hilarious
all right y'all have a good day
bye
[Music]